last night two Governors from two
different states with two entirely
different approaches to government who
each want to be president squared off on
Sha Hannity's show it was the sort of
debate that in a politically serious and
grounded country might have swayed the
public discourse and altered the course
of our nation but we are not that kind
of country anymore so it didn't do any
of that and nothing changed I'm Michael
Nolls this is the Michael NS
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by good ranchers head on
over to goodranchers.com to find all
your gifts this year use code NES kwas
to save a bonus of 10% off today on top
of their December sale Elon Musk is
hinting at who he might vote for in
2024 or he's at the very least hinting
at who he will not vote for we'll get to
that in one second first though I don't
want to move too fast off the DeSantis
Nome debate I watched the whole debate
it was it was a good
debate and right this morning all the
Democrats and even some of the
Republicans are reporting that Gavin new
someone and I don't really agree with
that I agree that Gavin Nome I don't
know looks taller or something Gavin
Nome is a little Slicker certainly than
DeSantis uh so some people are making
the comparison to the Nixon Kennedy
debate that on the substance Nixon would
have won the debate but Kennedy just
looked more glamorous so he won the
debate you know there's this Old Line in
politics probably apocryphal that the
radio audience believed that Nixon had
won because they were listening to the
ideas but the film audience the TV
audience audience thought that Kennedy
had won I I think DeSantis won I think
it was pretty clear that DeSantis won
the debate Nome was a formidable
opponent so right out the gate Dan
santis comes out he says look all the
people are moving out of your state
moving to my state your econom is
terrible you've got excrement on the
streets you know he just stated the
facts and the facts are so damning for
California you you thought man how on
Earth is Gavin Nome ever going to defend
his record it the it's just all right in
front of our eyes and Gavin
Nome did the best job I think anyone
possibly could and here's how I'm here
uh to tell the truth about the Biden
Harris record and also compare and
contrast Ronda sanz's record and the
Republican Party record as a point of
contrast that's as different as daylight
and darkness you want to bring us back
to a pre 1960s World America in Reverse
uh you want to roll back hard earned ear
National rights on voting rights on
civil rights on lgbtq rights on women's
rights not just access to abortion but
also access to contraception you want to
weaponize grievance you are focusing on
false separateness you in particular Ron
are on a Banning binge a cultural Purge
intimidating and humiliating people you
disagree with you and president Trump
are really trying to light democracy on
fire so Sean there are profound
differences tonight and I look forward
to engag him but there's one thing in
closing that we have in common is
neither of us will be the nominee for
our party in
2024 oh man that guy's good he's so
slick and D santis is not slick Des
santis is a little bit awkward and his
smile seems a little bit forced and
Ronda santis is just a bulldog he's just
a big Bulldog who gets into office and
wields power effectively and has a good
political vision and Gavin Nome has no
vision whatsoever and Gavin Nome has a
horrific record but he gave a great
answer there and and it's something that
the left the smart politicians on the
left have done for years which is that
if you're going to lose on the facts of
our society of our of of how their
policies are currently damaging people
then you got to reframe the debate away
from the realities of the present toward
the imagined horrors of the
past Joe Biden is so good at this Joe
Biden says oh you know I I completely
saved the economy you you think the
economy is bad now but man had Trump's
policies continued oh you would be so
much worse off oh it's it's horri you
can't even imagine oh yeah this World
War III in the Middle East it's it's bad
but you know the only reason they're
doing it is I was I was going to bring
peace to the Middle East this is you
think you think what you think it's bad
now man what the Republicans would have
done oh it hypothetically would would
have been absolutely terrible and the
the best way they do this is by
convincing everyone that the past was
really bad this is at the heart of
progressivism progressivism says the
past is evil and terrible and
undesirable and miserable and the
present is a crisis and the future is
going to be really really great trust me
that that's progressivism in 20 seconds
and so Nome says yeah ignore the
excrement on the street ignore the the
struggling economy in certain places
ignore the open borders ignore the crime
the rampant
crime the
50s
segregation back alley
abortions
oppression I don't know
regress going backwards all these
really abstract
things the worst aspects of our real
past coupled with imag imagined evils
that people today having a a Prejudice
for the present just believe occurred in
the past and because Dan santis is a
conservative that that accusation kind
of
sticks now how did Dan santis get out of
it Dan santis said yeah okay whatever
yeah I know the past was really really
terrible but I'm not governing in the
past I'm governing the president my
state so good uh Governor Nome that your
own father-in-law moved to it I talk to
a lot of the people that have moved from
California to Florida and we never used
to get people from California to Florida
or really anywhere in these CU why would
you leave California it's got the best
weather great excuse me sir so but one
of the things that I did I had I was
talking to a gentleman a
couple I'm going to let the debate
breathe but it's his turn let's take
let's take turns so I was talking to a
fellow who had made the move from
California uh to Florida and he was
telling me that Florida is much better
governed uh safer better budget uh lower
taxes all this stuff he's really happy
with the quality of life and then he
paused and he said oh by the way I'm
Gavin Newsome's father-in-law so we do
count Gavin's in-laws as some of the
people that have fled California um and
come to the State of Florida nice nice
look Ronda santis you might say he's not
the slickest he's not the prettiest he
doesn't smile the best but that guy
prepares he prepared for that debate and
Nome is a super smart politician too
Nome saw that attack coming a mile away
that's why he tried to interrupt him
that's why he tried to derail him but
DeSantis wouldn't get derailed DeSantis
just kept plowing through in a
respectful way until Hannity who was
actually a very good moderator given the
currently terrible tenor of these sorts
of debates Hannity said hey come on let
let Dan santis finish and then he
totally landed that ending he said yeah
you know look I talked to a lot of
people no no cut it out stop it Ron stop
talking and one of them who really loves
the government in my state and hates the
government in your state is is your own
son-in-law explain that so Nome he look
Nome was able to evade a lot of the
attacks all night because he's he's
Patrick baitman because he's American
Psycho Dan santis was prepared for that
too and and so he took a moment to pull
out of the actual issues of the debate
to talk about and to
acknowledge why desantis's performance
sometimes doesn't seem as strong as nuum
even when all the facts and arguments
are on desantis's side he said cuz
you're you're slick Wily over here this
guy has no record there's no I mean the
fact that you supported amnesty the fact
you supported Obama reforms those are
facts they're just simple facts the fact
that your greatest contribution
this I don't mind in I don't mind him
lying to me I don't mind Gavin lying to
me but I do mind him lying to you uh he
is sitting there saying that Joe Biden
is willing to solve this problem is
there anybody out there that actually
believes
created this so if he's willing to lie
to you about that you know he's lying to
you about all these other facts and
figures uh about all this other stuff
he's just throwing stuff out to see what
sticks against the wall this is a slick
slippery politician whose state is
failing people are leaving his State and
he's trying to run interference for his
failure this is a slick slippery
politician I love it because it's it's
so true and Des santis kept returning to
this it's a really good Campaign theme I
happen to think Des santis is right on
on one point probably only one point
which is that neither new some Nord Des
santis are going to be the nominee as of
right
now who knows lightning could strike but
as of right now the polls seem to show
the the structure of the race seems to
show that it's going to be Trump versus
Biden and if that is the case Trump
should follow this strategy from Dan
santis which is they're always going to
try to redirect to some hypothetical
past or present crisis they're always
going to try to to off foot the
Republican to distract them to to do a
Jedi mind trick on the public and Des
santis kept coming back to hey you have
eyes you have pocketbooks you have
budgets you have you have friends who
are being subjected to crime and all
sorts of
disorder these slick politicians are
lying to you but you know the truth you
know you just live it every day
what they are telling you is not true
now when you want to look really really
good whether you're having a
presidential debate or just going to
dinner on a Tuesday night you got to
check out Jus cell right now go to
genucell.com we all know the holidays
can be a little bit hectic the shopping
the cooking the never ending list of
things to do but fear not because I have
discovered a gift that is thoughtful and
transformative the gift of genus cell
skincare from now until Christmas genus
cell's most popular package has a
special discount for our listeners at
Jus cell.com
NOS treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute best skincare in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
fine line skin redness and sagging
jawline will disappear right before your
eyes with J youell's most popular
collection you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed to or your
money back you deserve to look and feel
your best this Christmas season go to
genucell.com love the company you know
the founder is a Copic Christian from
Egypt who left for the American
dream j.com nlls get this incredible
holiday discount every order is
instantly upgraded to free express
shipping that is genucell.com
nwle this is the top quality stuff out
there incredible deals because they know
that you are going to be a customer for
life that's how good it is jus.com
noes then okay there's only a couple
more things I want to point out from
this it was an instructive debate even
if it's not going to change the the
nomination in 2024 it it gave a lot of
good pointers for what the Republican
should do as DeSantis is squirming and
trying to trying to weasle his way out
of every single question Dan santis then
returns to the bread and butter issue
the bread and butter issue that the
squishes want to run away from the
Chamber of Commerce wants to run away
from the Republican establishment wants
to run away from but that serves
Republicans very very well and that
would be pointing out that the libs want
you to believe that a dude can become a
chick let me just say something about
parents rights cuz he says California
respects parents rights this is Rich
he's been telling a lot of Whoppers
tonight this may be the biggest in
California if you're a parent in Iowa or
New Hampshire South
Carolina minor child can go to
California without your knowledge or
without your consent and get hormone
therapy puberty blockers and a sex
change operation all without you knowing
or consenting how in the heck is that
you know honoring parents' rights when
you're bringing people from out of state
to go around their parents' backs and
getting life altering surgeries that is
radical that is Extreme that is an
assault on parents rights you know what
it's not for you to decide it's for the
parents to decide and the parents do not
kids going to these other
things let me stay on a followup let's
turn to the issue of education and
Humanity excellent
excellent argument Nome knows it so he's
trying to cut him off he's trying to
interrupt him what's so great about this
is one we know that works for
Republicans it got Glenn yunan elected
in Virginia it helped make Ron DeSantis
popular in Florida it's been a winner
contrary to what the squishes in the
establishment will tell you that
profoundly social issue about sexual
matters and things that we just should
ignore and only talk about our taxes or
whatever they want you no that social
issue works it is very persuasive to
people especially when you talk about
what the Democrats are doing to kids
especially when you talk about the
parental rights the other thing it does
is it takes a strength of disantis and
the Democrats and it uses it against
them namely that they're really slick
and attractive and it it takes their
slickness and their attractiveness and
makes it seem creepy it makes it seem
like they're turning that on children it
makes them look like groomers it makes
Gavin Nome look like he is luring kids
to disobey their parents come to
California and have weird sexual
procedures performed on them which is
what he's doing that's a that's an
entirely honest true attack and and all
of a sudden the Slick guy who looks like
kind of a d Giovani looks like a total
freaking creep so then it gets down to
the the closing arguments that they're
going to make Ronda santis with
discipline comes back to a closing
argument that the Republicans should
should Hammer again and again yes he's
in Decline yes it's a danger to the
country he has no business running for
president and you know Gavin Newsome
agrees with that he won't say that
that's why he's running his shadow
campaign uh he should not be running uh
he is not up to the job uh and it is
dangerous for this country well I'll
take I I will take Joe Biden at a 100
versus Ronda santis any day of the week
at any age in fact all of the fol you
think he's up to the job you think he's
100% I've been spending plenty of time
with
private D santis is saying look my
opponent here and all the Democrats they
say they think Biden's up to the job and
but you don't and just look at the
public opinion polling all the
Republicans All The Independents and a
lot of Democrats all agree maybe most
Democrats at this point agree Joe Biden
is obviously not up to the job I never
really like the guy but even if you did
like the guy he he is in serious mental
decline he exhibits that every single
day it is a danger to the country it's
caused National crises it's causing
International
incidents we all know it and so when you
Hammer that home not only does it make
the Democrat look bad not only does it
incline people to vote for a republican
but it also shows the Democrats to be
Liars because they're saying something
Joe Biden's fine he's doing great he's
he's totally confident he they're saying
something that everybody knows is a lie
and that everybody knows that everybody
knows is a lie very good closing
argument and the way you know the maybe
the biggest reason that I would give the
win last night to Ronda santis is
because D santis demolished nome's
arguments so devastatingly that Nome had
to return for his closing argument to
Absolute piffl meaningless platitudes we
all want to be loved we need to be loved
we all want to be protected respected
and connected I think there is a Unity
frame here okay uh you said it well I
mean I I Ron I have no doubt Ronda sis
loves this country I love this country
it's not about red versus blue it's red
white and blue the United States of
America and I think we're all better off
and we're all better off off and so I
appreciate this conversation I
appreciate you Ron being a family man
you got three incredible kids I
appreciate your wife your sacrifice and
I appreciate your military service but I
also appreciate we do have fundamental
differences about the fate and future of
this country and that's why I'm going to
be working so hard to get Joe Biden and
kamla Harris reelected in 2024 whoa
total C that guy had nothing that was
like the love child of Patrick baitman
and kamla Harris and they get to him
okay closing argument governor and he's
thinking shoot every case I made tonight
got knocked down Dan santis will will
exploit that uh look man look it's we're
all we want to be loved and connected
and directed and elected and man we
don't we do better when we do better not
we do worse when we do worse you know
it's not and then the best line of of
all of the meaningless little rap was
it's not it's not about red versus blue
it's red white and blue which is the L
famous rewrite copycat Barack Obama
impression I've ever
seen Obama F I also thought this was a
stupid line from Obama but it worked he
said listen there's not a red America
not a blue America the United States of
America and that was the moment that
everyone decided this guy was going to
be the first black president he was
going to be this Unity candidate who
spoke in these glowing and vague terms
hope and change well that doesn't really
work anymore
Nome is not nearly as inspiring a
candidate as Barack Obama and it's been
played out and and and all this hope and
change the the not a red not a blue just
a red white and blue this stuff was
exposed as being meaningless for eight
years under the Obama
Administration this is Gavin Nome got
called on by the
teacher and he hadn't done the reading
and he didn't have an answer to the
teachers question because the teacher
Ronda santis had already had already
dissected all of his arguments and he
just rambled rambled into nothing so all
of that to say really good debate for
DeSantis not going to change anything
about this race
but the the one good thing that could
come out of this is assuming that Trump
Remains the leader of the pack and is
the nominee he should take notes because
if you coupled that debate performance
just on paper the debate strategies the
talking points the attacks if you
coupled that with a little more humor a
little more Charisma a little bit little
more little bit of that Juna sequa of
president
koffe that would be a formidable
strategy and it it certainly would go a
lot better than the debate against Joe
Biden went back in
2020 now there's big news with the Trump
campaign and it's apparent Embrace of
black lives matter we'll get to that in
one second because we got to talk about
these things and when you want to talk
to your friends you got to check out
pure talk right now go to P talk.com
palk has you covered for the holidays
with a free Moto G 5G phone no gimmicks
no trade in necessary just sign up for p
talks unlimited talk unlimited text and
15 gigs of data you can get all of this
for just 35 bucks and you will get the
Moto g5g phone for free here's the deal
you need to move fast because these
phones are almost gone so if your
current phone is on life support upgrade
for free with P talk the new Moto g5g
boasts a two-day battery life an
exceptional quad pixel camera and a
whole lot more perer talk gives you
America's most Dependable 5G Network at
half the price make the switch today go
to Pur
talk.com kwes to get this exclusive
offer and select the plan that is right
for your family Pure Talk gives you
America's most Dependable 5G Network at
half the price so make this switch today
Pur talk.com kwes to claim your free
Moto g5g phone with a qualifying plan
Pure Talk simply smarter Wireless the
daily wire's first ever full length
comedy lady Ballers premieres tonight
8:00 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
dailywire plus the most triggering
comedy of the decade deserves our best
deal of the year so for a very limited
time we brought it back get 50 % off new
daily wi plus memberships these are
annual memberships the only way to watch
lady Ballers is with your dailywire Plus
Membership of course you're getting
access to everything daily wire has to
offer I'm being told that I cannot give
any spoilers but what I can tell you is
you will not believe what some of our
friends uh have done and who shows up in
this movie if you've not already seen
the wonderful and hilarious trailer for
lady Ballers take a
look in a world where women's
sports is being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
[Music]
Year guys this is serious sports can be
your pathway to a better life well like
yours please don't steal my catalytic
converter again winning matters it's the
key ingredient in becoming a winner now
maybe you should try it
sometime are you going to move I am not
let's cut to the chase I know you're not
a woman hey you don't know how he
identifies if you can beat though what
do you know about the US opens for the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day you this
is the way the world is now my
8-year-old daughter told me all about it
so a guy can become a girl with no
physical changes at all oh that's called
ginger fluid so I can be a woman on the
court and a man in the bedroom room I
can't believe it nice you mean when
you're sleeping yes Coach Alex we could
play basketball we'd have to get the
whole team back together it's time we're
in I'm in I'm in to play Lady balers M
up you a't a girl that's what I'm with
her live in my truth this is my
truth
from Heroes day one of being a girl
athlete I love being a girl to shoes we
could dominate every woman's sport
running swimming soccer I said sport
Felix it's ladies basketball Boys Nobody
watches excuse me are these seats
open never mind getting
dunks
and tucking
[Music]
trunks no she
didn't that's the biggest I've ever seen
on a lady I don't care lady
Ballers one can even be trans aged now
which provide shix with a wonderful
opportunity to relive all the
experiences that she missed out on in
school
streaming exclusively on daily wire plus
December
1st if you miss classic comedies like
dodgeball Blades of Glory Tropic Thunder
get ready these lady Ballers is the
return of the comedies we love we are
celebrating the release of DW's first
ever fulllength comedy by bringing back
50% off daily War plus annual
memberships right now when this deal is
gone it's gone for good don't be left on
the bench get your daily War Plus
Membership now for 5050 % off at
dailywire.com subscribe join us for the
premiere of Lady Ballers tonight at 8:00
p.m. Eastern on dailywire plus my
favorite comment yesterday is from mind
martyr who says this is why Elon is one
of the most uh Cutthroat successful
businessmen alive my father worked with
him personally for years he does not F
around oh interesting yeah I mean I I
would imagine that this guy is pretty
sharp and I've been skeptical of a lot
of Elon Musk projects before but the one
thing I would say is it's not a good
idea to bet against Elon Musk that guy
can pull a rabbit out of a hat and so
Twitter which was already slated to go
bankrupt before he got there and now
he's totally you mixed everything around
and change the rules change the
name some people are saying it's going
to be the end of Twitter maybe it will
be but I would not bet against Elon Musk
okay turning from the disantis new some
undercard debate to the top of the
ticket a BLM activist a co-founder of a
BLM chapter is endorsing Donald Trump
we've been used and abused for so long
by that party they don't value our vote
uh their policies are basically um
racist policies and I believe it's a
racist party Donald Trump is he's the
opposite he's he's going to tell you how
it is he's gonna give it you straight
Trump has done more for the black
community than I can any president I can
think of in my lifetime and he's not
alone in his criticism President Biden
faces dismal approval numbers among
black voters in key swing States joining
us now the co-founder of black lives
matter Road Island Mark fiser Mark
thanks so much for joining the program
um you know this is my favorite story of
the day because it identifies with what
I've seen in the barber shop all the
brothers for some reason right now are
turning Tides right now and I I just
wonder what is the big
reason I I think personally it's the
duplicity of the
Democrats the hypocrisy um we're not
stupid the brothers are not stupid we we
understand when someone's for us and
when someone is not okay so this
guy is saying look I used to be a big
BLM supporter but now I'm supporting
Donald Trump the way the way that
Trump's opponents and the Republican
Party are framing this is that Trump is
embracing BLM that's not really the case
this guy Mark fiser is saying yeah I'm
not I'm not not really a BLM activist
anymore I I left the left because
they're racist and it's they're not
helping black people and the black
people now are all going to start voting
for Republicans I hope this is the case
I I hope this happens I'm not holding my
breath for it because I've heard this
just about every single election cycle
of my lifetime I've heard this is going
to be the one where the Democrats lose
the black vote and it moves in a big
swing to the Republicans and it never
happens it never ever happens the
Democrats keep a roughly 90% hold on the
black vote and I'm I'm looking at the
same polling that everybody else is I
agree right now in the polling you
seeing a big swing among black voters es
especially among black men toward the
Republican Party toward Trump I agree
that if any candidate is going to shake
up the demographic voting patterns it's
going to be Trump because he's a weirdo
because he doesn't fit the mold of the
old Republican politicians so there's a
decent enough chance that the voters are
going to break that mold to for him I'm
just not holding my breath for it but
that's not even why I bring up this
story I bring up this story because of
what I think is a fairly dishonest
attack on Trump and it's the headline
Trump Embraces BLM because he sent out
this post on Truth social spoke with
Mark Fischer yesterday a great guy very
honored to have his and blm's support
I've done more for black people than any
other president linol in in parenthesis
Lincoln including 10-year funding for
historically black colleges universities
where they had none opportunity zones
Criminal Justice Reform and much more
thank you to
Mark
so I see why people are accusing Trump
of embracing
BLM but I think that this post on Truth
social is a roar shock test I don't
think it really tells you any new
information about Trump I think this is
a roar shock test for whether or not you
like Trump or you just hate Trump that's
what it's really about
because one way of reading it is Donald
Trump is honored to have blm's support
this guy's a leftist he's a radical I
don't know the other way to read this is
Donald Trump is a funny guy who's doing
a little bit of trolling and making a
joke I think it's pretty clearly the
latter here's my evidence because one
sentence after he says he's honored
first of all because he doesn't have BLM
support because this guy left BLM and
BLM no longer recognizes him so I see
that is a fact that is a little trollish
the very next sentence Trump says I've
done more for black people than any
other president now the obvious response
to that is well Lincoln freed the slaves
are you Donald really saying that you've
done more than Abraham Lincoln and Trump
he's not even unaware of that he
acknowledges that in this jokey way in
the Tweet I've done more than any other
president for black people Lincoln
question question mark not even okay
other than Abraham Lincoln no no he says
no I've actually I think I've done more
for black people even than the president
who freed the
slaves I don't I think he's joking I
think the 40-year Entertainer who had a
top show on network television and has
been a an entertaining comedic figure
for almost half a century now I think he
knows how to tell a
joke now he cites certain things here
that I don't like the Criminal Justice
Reform that jailbreak bill I I did not
like that that was a bad policy so I I
grant that there is sometimes a little
bit of a mixed bag here but I guess I
guess that's even my broader point to
why this tweet or this truth social post
doesn't upset
me we have in the case of trump a record
to look at does anybody really believe
that Donald Trump is going to invite BLM
to the White House we're going have
Secretary of State Patrice
cullers Secretary of the Interior Alicia
Garza I don't think so Trump very
clearly stood against that kind of
radicalism obviously but he speaks in
ways that are kind of ambiguous and
often just funny on the campaign Trail
what I would compare this to is When
Donald Trump waved the LGBT flag on the
campaign Trail you remember that LGBT
for Trump and he actually had the flag
upside down because he obviously doesn't
care about that issue at all and a lot
of people a lot of conservatives said
this guy he's a radical Pro LGBT
candidate he's a big leftist how could
conservatives even consider endorsing
him or voting for him and what some
people said at the time was yeah he's
just he's just happy to take people's
votes but he's not going to be a pro
LGBT rights activism president or
whatever and then he wasn't he gets into
office and the immediately reverses
Barack Obama's insane decision to
promote in the military he was just a an
ordinary president he promoted
conservative judges to the courts he
didn't he wasn't that he talked in one
way on the camp campaign trail that was
weaponized ambiguity that won votes that
got attention and then he governed in a
way that was basically solid and that is
what I think we're seeing here with Mr
Trump and
BLM now who is Elon Musk going to vote
for for
president
well in a lot of Elections it's not so
much who you vote for as who you vote
against see yourself voting for
President Biden
if if it's if a Biden Trump election for
example I think I would not vote for
Biden you'd vote for Trump I'm not
saying I'd vote for Trump but I
mean this is this is definitely a
difficult Choice here you know would you
would you vote for Nikki Haley Nicki
Haley by the way wants uh all social
media
um names to be osed as you know no I
think that's outrageous yeah no I'm not
going to vote for some Pro censorship
candidate oh it's going to be a
difficult Choice i' uh guess I don't
know I'm not going to vote for Biden not
going to vote for Nikki Haley he
says so what do we conclude from
this it means that look maybe he'll just
vote for Trump and he's just trying to
be KY about it I think Elon is
expressing something deeper here which
is that he opposes is the old
consensus and Nikki haly fairly or
unfairly has become a representative of
the old consensus she just got the big
endorsement of the coch network the coch
network used to be the force in
Republican politics it's still a major
Force but since 2016 things have changed
a little bit the the alternately
neoconservative and
libertarian uh talking points that once
drove the Republican Party they've
Fallen of favor the the shades of
conservatism of the Bush years or even
alternately the um Paul Ryan you know
fiscal Hawk just cut spending years
they're kind of
over likewise Joe Biden certainly
represents the old consensus because he
was around at the founding of the
country and I think he signed the
Declaration of Independence Elon Musk is
saying no
anyone who represents
the policies of 20 years ago or in
Biden's case you know 300 years ago I'm
not voting for that person we need
someone to shake things up and I think a
lot of people feel that way
now speaking of shaking things up not
just in the political order but in your
own life and in the broader Kingdom that
really matters the Eternal Kingdom you
ought to check out St Paul center right
now go to stpaul center.com I recently
had my friend Dr Scott Han on the show
he is the founder of the St Paul Center
which is one of the fastest growing
Catholic organizations in the world I uh
love Scott I think that he is one of if
not the leading Catholic Theologian
around today so important to so many
people and they are spreading the good
news and spreading biblical literacy the
St Paul Center's mission is to give you
the tools that you need to know to love
scripture better to become more
confident in your faith to most
importantly grow closer to Christ
himself in order to to achieve this the
St Paul Center founded a new digital
learning platform called EMAs Academy
EMAs Academy features over 20 video
courses book studies and original series
giving you the ability to learn from
world-class theologians like Dr Han and
Dr John bergsma as if you were right
there with them in the classroom start
learning more about church history how
to interpret the Bible the basics of
Christian prayer and more St Paul Center
stpaul
center.com m i h a l you can begin
exploring Aus Academy for free for the
first two weeks imagine what would be
possible if we could all fortify
ourselves with a deeper understanding of
scripture and Faith don't miss the
opportunity stpaul
center.com this mailbag is sponsored by
P talk go to peer talk.com nkw to claim
your free Moto g5g phone with a
qualifying plan take it
away hey Michael hope you're doing well
and I hope you had a happy Thanksgiving
my question is more on can you give me
advice on something I have been with my
fiance for about 3 years and we're due
to be married in June I am currently
looking into becoming a Catholic and
there's a parish near me that does do
the rcia all year round and I am looking
into that but he just basically is
stagnant in his relationship with God
which is not something that I want he
doesn't try to move forward in virtue or
reading the Bible or anything like that
and I feel like that's that's a very
important part of any relationship is to
center it around God and I don't really
know what to do there are some other
things that have to do with finance and
everything like that that he goes
backwards on instead of moving forward
and trying to get better it it's like
he's going backwards
and um I I he says that if I become
Catholic he'll be become Catholic but
he's doing it mostly just so that we can
be together and to please me I think and
that's not what I want and so any advice
will be helpful thank you you know the
advice that you want you you're not
asking me for the advice that you think
you're asking me
for you don't want to marry this guy you
you're making that quite clear you're
saying yeah this guy he's a complete
loser he's a loaf he's he he's not
virtuous at all he's a coward he's a
cuck he's a weakling he yeah he's
financially irresponsible he's just he's
just a total loser so what do you think
I should do
Michael I don't know whether he's a
loser or not all I know is what you just
told me but what I do know is that you
don't want to marry this guy and and
you're asking me for permission to break
up with him well if you want to break up
with him break up with him you don't
need my permission you don't need
anybody else's permission for that
you're not married yet so just break up
with him if you don't want to break up
with him then I think
what you have to identify is that your
issue here is not just exactly how he's
approaching religion look I was an
atheist for 10 years people can take
cirous Roots back home to the church and
and to the a right relationship with
God but everything you're complaining
about with regard to your boyfriend
right now gets to a deeper issue which I
guess ultimately is religious because it
comes down to Genesis 3 and that's
basically that your your boyfriend
doesn't want to take a leadership role
in in the
relationship he just wants to be a a
loaf and a a follower and uh just do
whatever you do and uh not have to grow
up and act like a man so that's the
problem and and if you do want to fix
the relationship and end up getting
married to him you you got to just tell
him to act like a man and shape up and
be a leader and or or else you know go
find someone else because you're going
to dump that zero and get yourself a
hero girl you know like that that's
really what what you're saying here but
from the way you're talking about you're
not saying look I love him we're he's
he's just so such a wonderful man and he
tries his best but no you're saying this
guy's just a total loser and I don't
really like him am I allowed to break up
with him please Michael yeah sure okay
fine and the reason probably that you
feel that way about him is because
because of that failure of leadership
women don't want some guy who's going to
be a little wimp or a s no no woman
wants that so if you want to keep them
around I would just get right to the
heart of the matter look sweet little
Alisa has had to do this to me not not
uh to quite the extreme that you're
describing here with your boyfriend but
but you know a m much shallower way but
still meaningful on Friday nights when
we're trying to figure out what to eat I
don't know when you know whenever we
want to go out to I Alisa says ma what
do you want to have for dinner and I say
I don't know what do you want to have
for dinner I don't know we could do
Italian yeah we could do Indian yeah we
could do I don't know we could get sushi
yeah what do you want I don't know what
do you want what do you want I don't
know what do you want ma you're the man
make a decision head of household
Genesis chapter 3 man up that's that's
the answer I say oh sorry girl you know
what you're right we're getting Sushi
you're right I got act like a man so I
would tell him that or just dump him if
you really don't like him at all next
question hey there Smokey Mike this is
BAS cigar enjoyer uh I had a theological
question um the Bible frequently
references God's Wrath and I was
wondering how this should be understood
because wrath is a sin of course it's
one of the seven deadly sins famously
and I was wondering if it's the case
that it's not a sin for God because God
is perfectly free in his nature or if
it's more a matter of there being a
misunderstanding of the word wrath or
maybe not a broad enough understanding
of the word wrath in different
situations similar to with how Pride can
also mean Filly a love for your country
or something like that or if it's maybe
a mix of both or something else I'm not
seeing
thank you it's it's not just because God
is perfectly free but I think more so
because God is perfectly good so wrath
is excessive anger or passion or uh
Vengeance so
um but nothing is excessive for God
because God is infinite so how about
Pride well let's go to the deadliest of
the seven deadly sins can God be
prideful God can't be prideful because
pride is excessive love of one's own
Excellence but God is infinitely
excellent and God is omniscient so it's
not that he's ignorant of his own
infinite Excellence he he does know it
so is he prideful no he can't be
prideful because he can't excessively
love his own Excellence because his
Excellence is infinite and his love is
infinite too so uh likewise with wrath
wrath is a deadly sin for human beings
because it is uh excessive
and uh because it is vengeful and
Vengeance Belongs to the Lord so so for
human beings when we take Vengeance into
our own hands and when when we fall into
excess that would be sinful but
Vengeance properly Belongs to the Lord
and God cannot fall into excess because
he's infinite and perfectly good so
uh sin for us because these these
behaviors these um you know this kind of
anger that you're referring to with
wrath is in in our case conditioned by
sin for God of course not at all
conditioned by sin because God is
perfect and without sin next
question Hey Dirty Mike Mr reality here
I wanted to ask you a question regarding
your sex robot topic from Monday uh
about how once they perfect Ai and these
robots then no one's going to get
married and have kids and the species is
going to die out cuz everyone's going to
be busy with their robots my question is
do you think this could actually lead to
a turn to older traditions of arranged
marriages where people married other
people who they didn't really love they
didn't want to be with just to have
heirs and propagate their line and then
they'll just go play with their robots
um most of the time and just do that to
propagate the line um do you think
that's a possibility or do you think
it's just going to be the end of
civilization As We Know It And
everyone's going to eventually die out
uh and why do you think that thanks
these are both extreme scenarios but if
it's going to be one of them it's going
to be the ladder and the the reason is
that our birth rate problem right now
already exists we're already a dying
civilization we don't even have the hot
sexy AI sex robots yet and I think
probably in Japan they already have
there Japan's always technologically
just a little ahead on these weird
things but uh we're already in that
conundrum and the reason we're in that
conundrum is because we can't plan for
the future because we've taken an
antihistorical view of politics we hate
our forbears we we uh have taken an
undisciplined approach to politics we we
hate disciplining the appetite to
cultivate the rational will uh so
because of that we spend every dollar we
get in fact we spend dollars that we
don't have We're a nation that is deeply
indebted and we borrow from our biggest
geopolitical adversary in in order to
fund our rampant spending the as Patrick
Denine the conservative political
philosopher pointed out the inheritance
that we now leave to our children
politically is is nothing but a mountain
of debt we don't we don't have kids
because we want to go to brunch more
often or we want to just go on lots of
fun vacations or we want to pursue our
career without any thought to anyone
else marriage or or certainly not kids
so we replace kids with dogs if we're
going to replace it with any living
being at all and that that's a problem
right now you can't you can't you can
blame a lot on the weird AI sex robots
you can't blame that that and that
problem doesn't seem to be getting
better anytime soon next question dear
executive grassy NS this is murder of
crows here if you don't mind I'd like to
borrow your noer hat for just a moment I
Envision a stage with two equally spaced
podiums two Governors approach from
either side one Governor walks past his
Podium to center stage and says hello my
name is Ron de santz and I'm a real
presidential candidate if you would like
to learn about any of my presidential
platforms or or donate to my candidacy
please go to Rhonda santisis awesome.com
if you would like to continue to live in
the hellhole that is California please
continue to listen to the fool over my
shoulder thank you for for your time and
good night as he leaves the stage the
governor flips nelini the bird and says
get bent any thoughts my thought is a
lot of people have these really nice uh
fanfiction scenarios about their
preferred candidates who aren't doing
well and I say this is someone who
really really likes Newsome and who
spent the entire first half of my show
talking about how great or no I really
don't like Nome pardon I really like
DeSantis and I spent the entire first
half of my show talking about how great
dandis is and how how well he did in the
debate but that being said he has not
been an effective presidential candidate
he's been a bad presidential candidate
and the reason he's been a bad
presidential candidate the way we know
that for a fact is that he's not on
track to be the nominee he isn't
improving his numbers he isn't
connecting with new groups of Voters
so even though I like him and I think
he's done a great job as governor and I
think that he did well in that debate
last night that doesn't matter that's an
my
preferences for the sort of things a
candidate says and does in office don't
necessarily constitute what makes a good
presidential candidate and so then
people come up with all this fanfiction
of well but actually imagine if Dan
santis did this imagine this right you
have to imagine is not happening in real
life and Trump love him or hate him he
has been an effective presidential
candidate
even not returning to the White House in
2020 in
2021 even whatever happened in the 2020
election even even granted that he won
he won in 2016 he won the presidency at
least one time and he was a very
effective candidate everyone
underestimated him and he connected so
you know you don't you don't really need
the fix ition with that guy and we can
he do it again can he repeat 2016 again
I don't know some people are skeptical
of that but if you're in the fanfiction
world it's because in reality your
candidate is is not doing very well the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
n scada has a check out for two months
free on all annual
[Music]
plans